[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de votre
fidélité pour cette troisième partie de
soirée spéciale une soirée spéciale
consacrée vous le savez aux élections
régionales et municipales après ce
premier tour un scrutin marqué par de
nombreuses surprises et un scrutin
marqué jérémy aussi par un fort taux
d'abstention
oui deux électeurs sur trois ne se sont
pas rendus aux urnes aujourd'hui 66 %
d'abstention et parmi les votants il se
dégage un score et un résultat que vous
allez voir sondage sortie des urnes
estimations pardon sortie d une heure ne
ipsos steria un autre partenaire ce soir
et c'est marié dufay la présidente
socialiste sortante qui sort en tête de
ce premier tour son score estimé à 26,6
pour cent des suffrages
suivent julien odoul du rassemblement
national gilles platret les républicains
denis thuriau la république en marche
ses quatre listes dépasse les 10% des
suffrages c'est à dire que ces quatre
listes ont le droit peuvent se maintenir
et être candidat dimanche de la semaine
prochaine pour le second tour suivent
à l'issue de ce premier tour la liste
des écologistes menée par stephanie mann
9,7 pour cent des suffrages stephanie
mann qui dépasse les 5% et qui peut donc
négocier avec l'une des listes arrivées
en tête l'une des quatre listes qui
dépasse les 10%
elle peut négocier pour fusionné sa
liste avec l'une de ses quatre listes
et puis enfin un bastien photo est
éliminé 4,4 pour cent et claire rocher
également lutte ouvrière 2,6 pour cent
voilà il pour discuter et analyser ces
résultats nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau françois patriat sénateur la
république en marche bonsoir à vous
fasse avoue dominique bourgois vous êtes
candidats pour leur rassemblement
national et à côté de voile un joyau
d'air ce soir à tous les deux alain
joyandet pour heller
je me tourne vers vous françois patriat
ce que vous êtes quelle est votre
analyse sur ses résultats ce que vous
êtes surpris ce soir surpris par
l'abstention non j'avais prévu depuis
plusieurs semaines qui aurait pas plus
de 35 % de votants parce que d'abord je
n'étais pas favorable depuis longtemps à
ce que les élections aient lieu
maintenant non pas pour des raisons
politiques mais pour des raisons
électorales voté aujourd'hui alors que
les gens sortent à peine glucosides
pense plutôt aux vacances qu'on est déjà
dans la campagne présidentielle future
avec des gens pour qui parler du
département et de la région
à ce moment là n'est pas la
préoccupation première c'est évident
les partis politiques ont souhaité fait
le forcing pour les élections ont lieu
maintenant on en paye le prix
l'abstention maintenant si vous me
demandez mon sentiment ce soir bien
entendu je considère que pour nous c'est
un échec pour nous est difficile c'est
vrai ce soir je vous reconnais savez
quand on fait de la politique il faut
savourer ces victoires y assumer ses
échecs comment vous les expliquer cet
échec pas d'abord alors les chaînes dans
l'élection
il faut comprendre que ce que je pensais
aussi c'est que compte tenu du contexte
que je viens d'évoquer la prime et la
notoriété était donné au sortant
marie-guite dufay ferrand secours ce
soir elle avait un bilan elle a fait
campagne sur son bilan elle a fait
campagne avec les crédits de l'état du
plan de relance du bleu des contrats de
plan et cetera des semaines avait reçus
beaucoup de ministres valérie le premier
ministre en personne qui est venu faire
campagne pour votre candidat istres qui
sont venus signer avec madame du fait
le contrat de plan le plan de relance
pour plusieurs dizaines de millions
qu'est ce que vous payez se définit donc
la notoriété notoriété données acquis
rassemblement national à l'extrême
droite et au sortant le au milieu quand
on a des candidats qui ne sont pas
sortant qui sont inconnus qui n'ont pas
pu faire campagne dont les tracts n'ont
pas été distribués 30% des tracks ne pas
distribuer des gens de la commune n'ont
pas reçu les documents savent pas qu'ils
dénient curio aujourd'hui quand on n'a
pas les moyens de faire campagne c'est
plus difficile
l'ours est pas une excuse si pas une
excuse c'était difficile
c'était plus difficile le résultat de ce
soir bien évidemment que j'aurais
souhaité qu'on fasse 15 ou plus le
souhaitaient les sondages se sont
trompés
ce soir on fait un peu plus de 12% par
rapport aux autres partis majoritaires
en france est pas si mal que ça enfin
effectivement ce soir il faut assumer
cela ce que je pense d'ailleurs c'est
que cette élection n'aura aucune
incidence sur l'élection de l'année
prochaine merci je vous
propose tout de suite qu'on retrouve en
duplex avec nous et pendant que
marie-guite dufay est en train de
s'installer
on va retrouver le candidat l air la
tête de liste et l'air gilles platret en
duplex depuis dijon avec nous bonsoir
gilles platret alors ce soir vous êtes
troisième j'imagine que vous êtes déçu
et ben même pas désolé de vous décevoir
je ne suis pas déçu je suis pas déçu
tout simplement parce que je ne regarde
pas que le pourcentage je regarde le
nombre de voix nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un contexte où l'abstention est
souveraine c'est d'ailleurs la seule
victoire que chacun puisse revendiquer
ce soir celle de l'abstention
et donc si vous avez entre les deux
tours un sursaut dès que du corps
électoral vous changer complètement le
résultat au deuxième
et c'est exactement ce sur quoi nous
avons travaillé cette semaine dès demain
matin avec deux réunions publiques l'une
mardi à besançon l'autre jeudi à dijon
et je vous garantis que cette victoire
on va aller la chercher
même avec les dons gilles platret vous
pouvez pas gagner ce alors vous avez
toujours 10 mois pour le deuxième tour
je ferais alliance avec personne vous
maintenez cette position mais bien
entendu quand on a fait une alliance
aussi large que celle qu'on a réalisé
entre les deux tours avant le premier
tour par dont on va pas chercher à en
faire une différente au deuxième tour ça
on est très clair je vais laisser les
gens qui sont sur votre plateau négocier
cette nuit les petits arrangements entre
amis pour savoir comment ils vont se
présenter devant les électeurs à partir
de demain pour nous nous avons fait un
rassemblement large de la droite
républicaine et des écologistes
indépendants et c'est la base sur
laquelle nous présentons au deuxième
tour bien évidemment vous savez quand
vous avez sept électeurs sur dix qui
n'ont pas voté
il suffit qu'un électeur sur dix de plus
se déplace entre les deux tours pour
changer complètement les perspectives
électorales et le résultat du deuxième
tour
c'est là dessus que nous travaillons
gilles platret julien au dos le candidat
à la tête de liste du rassemblement
national qui vous devance d'un peu plus
de deux points ce soir a fait appel à
vos électeurs sur notre plateau il ya
quelques minutes que lui répondez vous
rien vous savez bien que je ne discute
pas avec cet individu
voilà il parle très bien pour lui-même
et ceux qui en parlent le mieux ce sont
ses amis qui ont appelé à le faire
battre d'ailleurs ça plutôt marcher
parce que par rapport aux sondages que
vous nous présentiez il est 13 ans de ça
il n'y a pas de discours à voir avec cet
individu nous parlons aux électeurs va
certainement pas à monsieur odoul merci
gilles platret d'être intervenu en
direct dans cette soirée électorale
merci à vous voilà on va continuer cette
émission avec une image peut-être
l'image de la soirée jérémy on va la
découvrir cette image elle a été tournée
en la préfecture de dijon
tout à l'heure on y voit marie-guite
dufay et stéphanie modde en pleine
conversation dans une petite salle elle
de la préfecture de dijon voilà la porte
de se refermer
marie-guite dufay je me tourne vers vous
qu'est ce qui se passe les négociations
ont déjà commencé pas du tout attention
aux interprétations alors dit tout car
excité de l'ani me dépasser pour des
raisons techniques
au milieu de cette pièce c'est le hasard
a complètement nous nous sommes salués
et nous savons que nous allons nous
retrouver ça c'est pas un scoop 1 c'est
pas un scoop
nous savons que nous allons nous
retrouver après cette émission
marie-guite dufay on va reparler en des
négociations et de du second tour de la
perspective dans laquelle vous projetez
mais d'abord votre sentiment sur le
premier tour est ce que c'est un score
inespéré pour vous non mais tout d'abord
c'est l'abstention
on peut pas commencer à comptes commenté
ces élections sans parler de
l'abstention je la redoute et je la
sentais je la voyais venir comme tout
comme tous les candidats un là elle est
terrible elle est catastrophique pour la
démocratie et elle est tellement
importante cette abstention
qu'effectivement les pronostics doivent
être très très prudent pour la suite et
que la vigilance doit être entière et le
combat doit absolument continuer moi je
ne ferai pas de pronostic précis compte
tenu du poids de cette abstention vous
ne faites pas mal votre sentiment parce
qu'on vous vous attendiez certainement
pas être aussi on sortira mon sentiment
forcément je peux pas vous dire que je
ne suis pas satisfaite d'être en tête de
toutes les listes bien entendu bien
entendu mais rien n'est gagné
je m'inscris en faux contre ce que j'ai
entendu sur vos antennes les
tripatouillages les magouilles
je ne sais quoi entre les deux tours
j'ai toujours dit parler du lion 12 pas
que les gens meurent ici j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours dit que je conduisais une
liste de gauche une liste de gauche qui
n'a pas su rassembler au premier tour
j'ai rassemblé le ps le prg parti
communiste un certain nombre de membres
de la société civile ce n'est pas réussi
à rassembler au-delà la gauche
je vais continuer je vais continuer
parce que pour moi il est naturel
d'avoir une alliance avec les
écologistes et pas du tripatouillage
c'est pas démago viennent ça veut dire
ma règle et du fait qu'il y aura des
candidats de stéphanie modde sur votre
liste dimanche prochain à ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on trouve un accord en
bonne et due forme cette nuit j'espère
que nous l'aurons vous l'avez
préparez-vous discutait depuis plusieurs
jours encore hier vous discutiez oui sur
le fond et après il ya la forme ja est
ce que vous êtes prête ce soir intégré
sur votre liste des démarcheurs je pense
que j'ai la réponse mais je vous la pose
quand même
non mais moi la question ne se pose pas
la question se pose de rassembler la
gauche parce que pour vous regardez la
gauche et que vous faites les additions
quant au lait la gauche elle fait
rempart au rassemblement national donc
la question ne se pose pas vis-à-vis de
mme alors soit vous êtes à côté un peu
de poésie
françois patriat je crois que vous
connaissez très bien à temps s'il avait
une partie du décor qui vous tombe
dessus
vous avez tous les deux vraiment vous
étiez président de bourgogne de
franche-comté vous avez oeuvré pour la
fusion vous entendiez bien oui puis on
continuera à bien son temps c'est pas le
sujet 1 le sujet là je crois qu'il faut
être clair par rapport aux électeurs les
électeurs qui sont déboussolés vous
voyez bien cette abstention
elle nous renvoie quand même une image
absolument déplorable dans la tête des
gens de la politique donc aujourd'hui il
faut être clair je conduis une liste de
gauche parce que effectivement je suis
de gauche avec effective et d une gauche
qui n'est pas complètement rassemblé que
je cherche à rassembler jusqu'au bout
les marcheurs c'est autre chose
alain joyandet oui merci de me donner la
parole bonsoir demeure j'aurai saluer
mais mes collègues mais j'écoutais
madame du féliciter pour son score de
premier tour mais j'écoutais j'écoutais
françois patriat mans puis je vous vois
tous les deux là
et je veux dit quand même quand vous
dites que les électeurs doivent être
déboussolé il ya de quoi en vous
regardant tous les deux parce que je
vous rappelle quand même que lors de la
dernière élection
vous étiez président de la région
franche comté
françois patriat la région bourgogne
vous avez été en sans bras dessus bras
dessous voir le premier ministre pour
expliquer qu'il fallait absolument
fusionner cette région la fusion est
quand même un échec
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est un échec
c'est un échec budgétaire c'est un échec
psychologique pour un certain nombre de
2 de franck maurice a pas plus les
préjudices marie-guite dufay dans le jeu
je reconnais que ça n'a pas prêté
préjudice à marie-guite dufay je pense
qu'elle la présidente a bien fait comme
de mettre quelques réserves parce
qu'elle 70% des gens qui sont restés
chez eux mais j'ai comment voulez vous
que les gens soient pas déboussoler
puisque vous étiez des alliés et vous
êtes en train d'expliquer aujourd'hui
que je n'ai pas besoin de l'art m mais
sur d'ailleurs surtout pas besoin de la
reine puisque pour avoir les écologistes
au deuxième tour il faut pas vous ayez
la reine il faut parler un peu feront
faut que les électeurs comprennent pas
ce que je pense
voyant déjà les besoins la reine dans
certaines régions des écolos c'est pas
la gauche
non mais attendez je faisais pas
interrompu madame du fait je veux dire
que nous les choses pour nous les choses
sont claires on a présenté une liste au
premier tour et on présentera la même
liste au deuxième tour mais vous avez
fait alliance avec l'as raismes en paca
et vous fait alliance avec debout la
france ici en bon coin de franche-comté
donc les électeurs peuvent aussi dures
conditions bourgogne franche comté et je
vois ce qui s'est passé en bourgogne
france comté depuis six ans joue pas
c'est juste pour pour rappel c'est
seulement à ceux causés les électeurs
sont déboussolés vous savez ce qui se
passe en paca je ne trouve pas que c'est
terrible non plus donc je regarde les
choses globalement je pense que
politiquement avec ce qui s'est passé
depuis 4 ou 5 ans on peut comprendre que
les électeurs soit déboussolé et je
rejoins françois patriat sur un point
parce que je pense que cette élection
s'est déroulée à un moment qui n'est pas
bon j'avais aussi le vrai je l'avais dit
publiquement
j'avais souhaité que cette élection soit
organisée plus tôt à l'automne en
septembre ou octobre
je pense qu'on aurait eu beaucoup plus
de participation je pense que les
résultats auraient été sans doute
différent aussi en terme de
participation
tout le monde vous dira alain joyandet
mais on peut aussi imaginer que beaucoup
dans l'opposition aurait crié
haro sur la démocratie si les élections
avaient été à nouveau reporté mais moi
si vous les jeux je parle pas je pourrai
pas la place des autres je vous rappelle
la position que j'ai prise
médiatiquement aussi nous montrez vous
bien le bien entendu mais on est on est
là pour repris mais aussi nos personnes
on n'est pas en plus des des gens
affiliés à toutes les idées je pense
qu'on peut on peut quand même expliquer
aussi les choses pour 7 abstentions et
je regrette vraiment cette abstention et
je conclue en disant que comme l'a dit
gilles platret du coup du coup il faut
pas faire trop de prévisions précises
pour dimanche prochain
parce qu'il suffirait qu'un tout petit
peu de gens viennent en plus voter
dimanche prochain pour que les résultats
soient sensiblement changé je le
souhaite et je lance un appel d'ailleurs
sans doute que ceux qui nous écoutent à
cette heure ci sont sans doute des gens
qui sont venus voter qui s'intéressent à
la politique ceux à qui on voudrait
passer un message c'est sans doute ce
qui ne nous écoute pas qu'ils sont chez
eux qui sont pas du tout intéressés par
cette élection et à qui on voudrait dire
venez parce que c'est quand même la
démocratie en rappel qui a eu dix points
de plus de participation entre les deux
tours en 2015 olivier bourgois
dominique aubert excusez moi olivier
c'était votre notre colistiers du 71
tout à l'heure le rassemblement national
est particulièrement touché par cette
très forte abstention comment vous
l'expliquez jeu des difficultés à
expliquer précisément ce que vous dites
parce que selon les périodes et selon
les échéances électorales et les
résultats tantôt l'abstention
profiterait au rassemblement national et
tantôt et devrait contre lui donc je
pense que tout ça c'est c'est très très
subjectif
la réalité c'est que les sept électeurs
qui ne se sont pas prononcés qui ne se
sont pas déplacés pour aller voter sont
probablement à répartir sur l'ensemble
des candidats dans lequel c'est vous qui
a reculé le plus sain par rapport à 2015
que oui probablement après
voilà il y à des résultats qui sont ceux
que vous connaissez qui sont tombés ce
soir maintenant je pense que pour nous
notre objectif de deuxième tour ça va
être effectivement de rassembler on est
d'accord sur le fait que l'assemblée
pardon rassemblé comment rassembler
entre pardon et avec qui et bien
rassembler avec tous ceux qui qui
confirmeront nos valeurs entre guinée
parce que là encore une fois il ya
beaucoup d'excès et des excès de langage
l'extrême droite et c'est des choses
complètement owni qui dans le fond ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
la campagne très à droite de gilles
platret qui c'est s'assumer de droite
elle vous a fait mal il vous vous
appliquez des électeurs en ce
positionnement comme il l'a fait je ne
le pense pas je ne pense pas il a il ya
probablement troubler son camp il a
probablement troubler ses électeurs mais
encore une fois les électeurs
n'appartiennent pas à des candidats les
électeurs appartiennent un mouvement
d'idées
moi ce que je constate simplement c'est
que dans cette abstention qui est très
forte aujourd'hui c'est un peu la
démocratie qu'on met en sourdine et ça
c'est un problème majeur
mais on a un tour pour se refaire et
pour ce qui nous concerne permettre à
nos électeurs de dire par rapport à une
présidence sortante
stop ou encore françois patriat -2 12%
pour denis thuriau ya un problème
d'appoint mais si on pousse 80 donc il
ya un problème des importations et de la
république en marche au niveau local
pour blanche pourrait faire un peu de
cocorico nous étions 0 nous faisons 12
fallait nous étions 0 il ya trois ans
nous n'existions pas et j'ai fait
campagne avec marie-guite dufay
déjà je suis drôle c'est une drôle de
manière
quand même de commenter
fait campagne avec de dialoguer avec
variés du feu j'ai fait campagne avec
marine buffet dont je salue la victoire
même la progression par rapport à ce
qu'elle fait la dernière fois
lb nous à lapalud ce qu'elle a déjà
gagné elle bénéficie je pense qu'il est
en bonne voie pour gagner oui elles
bénéficient de la prime au sortant
elle a pu faire campagne sur son bilan
inauguré signé avec le premier ministre
avec madame goût rôle des plans de
relance le contrat de plan et madame
madame buffet s'est très bien m'appeler
quand elle a besoin de parler au premier
ministre pourrait demeurer public et pas
de problème voilà c'est parce que c'est
pas alors aujourd'hui présidente du
collectif odessa rien entendu bien
entendu j'entends bien mais quand
j'entends dire aujourd'hui je veux
rassembler à gauche que la gauche moi je
suis aujourd'hui pour le dépassement
politique je l'éprouvé et je pense que
je les mêmes prouvé l'année dernière aux
sénatoriales dans les gagnants je
l'éprouvé l'année dernière je suis pour
le dépassement politique pdg s'est donc
posé la question
donc ce soir jeudi à madame du fait que
je connais et avec qui j'ai beaucoup
travaillé
est-ce que ce soit vous êtes en capacité
de discuter avec nous pour élargir votre
majorité et faire en sorte d'assurer
guide du maître victor est ce qu est ce
que vous pouvez discuter avec nous voilà
vous dit alors si et ben on va laisser
répondra reggae du filet ce sera une
nouvelle version du programme commun de
la gauche
marie-guite dufay marie-guite dufay nous
que nous parle aussi je ne change pas de
discours par rapport à ce que j'ai dit
je rassemble les forces de gauche et
donc la république on marche ne fait pas
partie des forces doivent discuter pas
avec nous non non vous ne serez pas donc
c'est une fois nous recevoir nous vous
tendons la main
nous voulons vous aider à gagner mieux à
élargir votre majorité
à voir demain par des gens d'expérience
avec vous et donc c'est un refus de
votre part c'est quand même très
compliqué à ces jeux d'équilibré
politique parce que il y a quand même un
certain nombre de le faire a donné huit
sièges au parti communiste
il ya un certain nombre à oui et je suis
fier monde et j'en suis fier donc
aujourd'hui il faut être clair avec les
électeurs je les étés depuis les débuts
je veux rassembler ceux qui se
retrouvent dans les valeurs de la gauche
merci à tous les deux on va poursuivre
la discussion mais tout de suite on va
parler des départementales il ya aussi
les départementales ce soit réglé on va
partir rejoindre 4e série et gabrielle
talon c'est à vous
merci merci' elsa en effet cet anneau
pour les départementales
juste quelqu'un petits points déjà en
franche comté pour les départementales
trois présidents sont déjà réélu dès le
premier tour il s'agit d'yves krattinger
en haute-saône de florian bouquet dans
le territoire de belfort de clément
pernot dans le jura et concernant
christine bouquin du doubs elle est en
ballottage très favorable puisqu'elle a
recueilli plus de 70% des suffrages mais
le fameux quotas du quart des inscrits
n'étaient pas atteints je vais vous
parler également puisque je suis dans le
doubs du pays de montbéliard on
attendait des résultats donc de 2,4
primaire qui à gauche qui avait lieu
dans ces départements
donc regardons tout d'abord bethoncourt
bethoncourt que je n'ai pas pu vous
donner tout à l'heure parce que le
résultat est tombé un petit peu plus
tard et bien c'est le rassemblement
national qui arrive en tête dans le
canton de béthoncourt magali duvernois
qui faisait équipe en 2015 avec philippe
claudel est arrivé en deuxième position
philippe claudel lui en troisième
position est éliminé pour le second tour
donc on voit là que dans le cette
primaire à gauche c'est la gauche de la
gauche donc savoir le ps et des divers
gauche qui l'ont emporté devant des
divers gauche beaucoup plus modérée ce
qui fait que dans le pays de montbéliard
où nous avions la gauche divisée à
audincourt bavent bethoncourt et
valentigney eh bien le et rennes se
qualifie à tous les coups pour le second
tour à audincourt il sera opposé à au ps
et aux divers gauche à bavans il sera
opposé aux républicains qui arrive en
tête dans ce département
voilà et puis à bethoncourt
le rn sera opposé au ps divers gauche et
à valentigney la république en marche
donc sera opposé au rassemblement
national la république en marche et
notamment le député et l'air em frédéric
barbier j'ajoute également que
concernant le rassemblement national
il est qualifié également pour le second
tour dimanche prochain à baume les dames
avec jacques richard des ti est égal
à mèche le canton de la présidente
christine bouquin pour dimanche prochain
donc face à un binôme heller maintenant
je vous donne la parole gabriel des
résultats des réactions en direct que
nous proposez vous pour les
départementales en bourgogne ils meurent
aller faire un petit tour dans la nièvre
mais juste avant puisque vous parliez de
président réélu et bien on va aller en
côte d'or pour donner les résultats du
canton de semur en auxois où vous le
voyez le président udf françois sauvadet
réélu dès le premier tour on reviendra
en côte d'or tout à l'heure on va
maintenant aller dans la nièvre pour
regarder ce résultat celui du canton de
corbigny
c'est là que se présentait le chef de
file des socialistes fabien bazin et
vous le voyez il est en ballotage face à
un candidat de la nièvre
ensemble on va le retrouver tout de
suite en direct de nevers fabien bazin
bonsoir est ce qu'on peut dire que et
bien ce soir les socialistes ont bien
résisté dans la nièvre
oui on a bien résisté d'ailleurs c'est
pas simplement les socialistes mais
vivre la nièvre quitte à un mouvement
citoyen qui rassemble des personnes de
gauche bien entendu on a plusieurs
candidats aujourd'hui qui sont en
ballottage très favorable
on a vu à lille il ya eu de la perte de
la mairie de nevers on a vu château
chinon également tombés l'année dernière
ce soir c'est un peu c'est le début d'un
coup d'arrêt on va dire de cette érosion
du pouvoir socialiste dans la nièvre
oui encore une fois ne parlons pas de
pouvoir socialiste mais de citoyens
engagés à gauche en autour de son
engouement vivre la nièvre nous avons
construit avec les nivernais aujourd'hui
à château chinon fait mieux que résister
pas très jolie est en ballottage très
favorable si on n'avait pas eu la règle
des 25 %
justin guyot serait élu à 2,6 ou
jocelyne guérin à luzy et l'oncle sommes
dans une grande majorité de cantons
aujourd'hui la dynamique et bien du côté
de vivre la nièvre soudan nous
félicitons ça veut dire que pour ce
deuxième tour vous vous êtes c'est vrai
on va falloir encore batailler
il faudra batailler d'abord contre
l'abstention qui est quand même le fléau
de cette de cette élection et puis il
faut toujours se bagarrer dans une
élection s'est jamais acquis d'avancé
aujourd'hui on lance un appel au haut
nivernais pour qu'ils retournent vers
les urnes au deuxième tour pour nous
accorder cette majorité et construire
une belle équipe renouvelée et
rassembler merci beaucoup
on va maintenant partir prendre à moins
que catherine danion oui on va
maintenant voilà on va maintenant
prendre donc la direction va partir à
auxerre où doit nous attendre jean
christophe letien bonsoir bonsoir on a
donné déjà donné quelques résultats pour
pour l'yonne on va maintenant regarder
celui ci si vous le permettez celui de
villeneuve sur yonne puisque c'est le
canton qui avait élu en fait un binôme
rassemblement national il y a 6 ans et
on le voit dans ce canton le binôme est
reine arrive en deuxième position
derrière le binôme de la droite soit
presque le tiers sont un peu commenté
les premiers résultats de cette soirée
est ce qu'on peut dire ce soir que le
rassemblement national est en recul par
rapport à 2015 écoutez on peut surtout
dire que
la participation est en recul et on peut
surtout constater que nos électeurs ne
sont pas venus ne se sont pas déplacés
dans la majorité on peut aussi constater
qu'une majorité de binôme est en seconde
position quelques uns sont en tête
et naturellement il va falloir le pâté y
est la semaine prochaine comme nous le
faisons systématiquement est toujours de
la bêtise assure vous avez des arrêts
nous écouter à vide et assure qu des
deux cantons vous serez présent au
deuxième tour dans l'yonne non non j'en
arrive à la préfecture on a découvert
des résultats au fur et à mesure et je
cache pas que j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
prendre la totalité la totalité des
résultats
c'était il ya cent ans était clair qu'il
ya six ans assurément ce sera moins
peut-être peut-être mais en fait on a un
deuxième tour la semaine prochaine
et j'invite sur tous nos concitoyens les
icaunais à regarder la possibilité
qu'ils ont de changer les choses
et puis de regarder également ce qu'ont
fait les sortants puisqu'elle bénéficie
en effet d'une prime est la fameuse
prime aux sortants que l'on voit et que
l'on constate
mais il faut vraiment regarder ce qui a
été fait ce qui est prévu de faire et en
général ce n'est pas ce qui est attendu
par l'ensemble des icaunais donc il faut
vraiment se pencher sur le problème se
mobiliser dès la semaine prochaine et me
souvenir sur le terrain dès demain merci
merci beaucoup jean-christophe le tiers
s'en va s'intéresser maintenant à
nouveau la france comptait avec vous
catherine oui avec tout d'abord quelques
résultats importants tout d'abord dans
le territoire de belfort à bavilliers
deux binômes s'opposaient et le binôme
sortant composé donc notamment du maire
de bavilliers eric oberlé qui a changé
partenaire depuis la dernière fois avec
des fils maki est en deuxième position
alors c'est un on peut pas parler de
ballotage favorable ou défavorable
puisque madame b luchez et monsieur
formés sont devant à 50,70 % mais ça
veut dire 42 voix simplement de
différence entre ces deux minots donc là
les choses sont extrêmement tendues dans
le canton de bâle ville est maintenant
en haute saône de résultats importants à
savoir à gré il y avait un duel entre
claudie chauvelot du banc qui est non
seulement première vice présidente au
département de haute saône meg
mon conseil régional sortant qui se
retrouvaient opposé à christophe
laurence aux divers droite ll est donc
ps lui divers droite le maire de grey et
là les résultats sont les suivants donc
en ballottage claudie chauvelot du banc
et laurent bailly avec presque 42 % des
voix christophe laurenceau et annie
gabiot divers droite avec un peu plus de
38%
là aussi de tout comme donc le rn est
battu pour cette élection
et puis à port-sur-saône c'était un nom
quand on teste puisque le binôme
sortants ne se représentaient pas il
était à gauche et bien ce canton donc se
retrouve en avec donc le duo de gauche
en position favorable pour dimanche
prochain puisque 45,50 % des voix suivi
des divers droite et l'air
sandrine robin et luc simonel le rnd
battu dans ce canton
voilà donc puisque nous parlons du
rassemblement national qui n'a pas
réalisé de très bons scores pour le
moment en eau sur une pour les résultats
que nous avons nous attendons donc les
villes de héricourt et de lure avec vous
beaucoup d'impatience mais nous allons
tout de suite à t'entendre son chef de
file à savoir donc antoine villedieu du
rassemblement national de haute saône
on écoute toute façon l'objectif est
toujours le même
et puis on lâchera rien puisqu'on le
sait que on est très fort dans le
département notre objectif de
l'entre-deux-tours savez d'aller
expliquer et à nos électeurs qu'il faut
se mobiliser parce qu'on peut gagner
parce qu'on va gagner et aussi de tendre
la main
dans certains cantons où il serait
orphelin de candidats républicains de
leur expliquer qu'aujourd'hui s'ils
veulent faire barrage à la gauche
c'est avec le rassemblement national et
c'est sur un projet concret qui a été
fait pour eux qu'ils pourront retrouver
un petit peu foi en la politique
donc c'est antoine gillet du
rassemblement national de haute saône de
gabriel quelques résultats pour la
bourgogne
oui et on va laisser pas catherine au
valais en côte d'or avec baume tout d'un
bord et on le voit fait le binôme
pierres volent vers le diffuseur qui
arrive en tête devant marie laure a kick
et jean-benoît vite
mais autrement dit un duel de droit pour
le second tour on va les voir également
maintenant du côté de montbard montbard
c'est le canton où se présentait la
députée yolaine de course au qui cette
fois se présentait pour la gauche si on
le voit les qualifiés pour le second
tour dans un ballotage avec et face à
marc frot et laurence porte de la
majorité sortante et enfin sur le canton
de dijon 2 on voit ce résultat celui de
la sortante nathalie koenders en tête
avec 47 73 % et qui sera donc face un
binôme l air au second tour nathalie
koenders on va d'ailleurs tout de suite
la retrouver en direct de dijon nathalie
koenders bonsoir quelle quelle analyse
vous faites tout simplement de cette
soirée pour la gauche en côte-d'or
bah écoutez je tiens déjà à remercier
l'ensemble des côte d'oriens qui sont
déplacés pour aller voter et plus
particulièrement les dijonnaises et les
dijonnais ceux du canton de dijon 2
c'est vrai que notre programme arrive
dans de nombreux cantons en tête donc il
va falloir transformer l'essai au second
tour et j'appelle vraiment tous ceux qui
sont déplacés à venir pour le second
tour non je n'ai pas encore les
résultats définitifs mais je sais qu'on
a des très bons résultats sur dijon avec
l'ensemble des binômes qui sont soit
devant mais en tout cas ils sont tous
qualifiés pour le deuxième tour
en tout cas on sent pas dans votre voix
un enthousiasme dingue il n'y a pas eu
une vraie poussée de la gauche ce soir
en côte d'or
si mais écoutez vous savez moi je suis
prudente et je me concentre maintenant
sur le deuxième tour je pense qu'il faut
vraiment et bien inciter les gens qui
sont déplacés à venir voter et puis
aussi inciter les abstentionnistes en
tout cas c'est ce que je fais ce soir
pour voter pour nos candidats pour un
département plus humain plus solidaire
plus écologie c'est plus attractif
avant de se quitter juste un mot
nathalie koenders on a beaucoup commenté
on a beaucoup vu un recul du
rassemblement national c'est valable
dans les autres départements vous le
constatez également côte d'or ben oui
effectivement les sondages finalement
n'ont pas été commentées je trouve pas
le terme pardon mais on voit
effectivement à notre recul donc on peut
et bien s'en félicite et maintenant on
voit qu'il ya eu quand même beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi peut-être allez leur
expliquer l'importance de ce vote leur
expliquer les compétences des
collectivités de la région du
département qui sont quand même des
compétences essentielles dans la vie
quotidienne et je pense notamment au
département puisqu'il s'occupe voilà de
la naissance jusqu'au grand âge donc
c'est à nous de leur de cette semaine du
deuxième tour d'aller leur expliquer
l'importance de ces deux élections
merci de ta bécane birth et on retourne
en france remonte à quatre mains oui
nous allons tout d'abord aller dans le
doubs pour entendre christine bouquin
christine bouquin c'est la présidente et
l'air du département du doubs elle sera
opposée dimanche prochain à un binôme du
rassemblement national
elle aurait pu être élu dès le premier
tour qui avait vu plus d'électeurs dans
son canton
mais en fait elle n'atteint pas le
fameux quotas du quart des électeurs
inscrits avec plus de 70% des voix donc
sur le canton de mèche
donc c'est vrai qu'elle est en position
très favorable est l'une de nos équipes
la rencontre est tout à l'heure voici sa
réaction
nous l'écoutons suis très satisfait que
la plupart des équipes de la majorité
départementale c'est le doubs soit
qualifié pour le deuxième tour et soient
devant dans certains cantons
nous allons poursuivre l'ensemble de
nos actions vous avez compris quand nous
sommes devant comme ceux ci c'est
l'abstention qui nous a fait trébucher
donc on va recommencer dès demain matin
et aller chercher un par un les
électeurs pour que nous puissions mener
notre programme pour les six ans à venir
je suis très confiante mais je parle
avec beaucoup d'humilité parce qu'il n'y
a pas beaucoup de taux de participation
et c'est très inquiétant donc c'était
christine bouquin à la présidente et
l'air du département du doubs maintenant
on retourne en bourgogne pour quelques
résultats à gabriel oui quelques
résultats catherine est tout d'abord
ceux de mac ont tout d'abord sur le
canton de mâcon on le voit donc c'est le
maire de la ville jean patrick courtois
et christine robin qui arrive en tête
avec 47 30 % ils seront au deuxième tour
face à un binôme de gosses de l'alliance
grsp europe ecologie les verts
et puis à peu près même cas de figure
sur le canton de mâcon 2 cette fois
c'est claude canet hervé reynaud qui
arrive en tête avec 39 78% devant un
binôme la france insoumise parti
communiste et puis catherine avant de
vous rendre la parole ou encore koné
votre quand tout va bien encore de
résultats dans l'yonne cette fois avec
le canton de gastines et en bourgogne
plus que là il s'agit il s'agissait de
la succession du poste de jean baptiste
lemoyne et vous voyez donc ces résultats
qui s'affichent
il y aura un second tour un duel entre
la droite et le rassemblement national
il y avait une sorte de primaire
catherine à droite sur ce canton
et c'est bien le binôme investi par la
majorité départementale qui l'a emporté
un dernier résultat pour l'yonne avec le
canton de joigny vous allez voir les
résultats dans un instant et là vous le
voyez donc c'est la gauche qui arrive en
tête c'est là que se présentait frédéric
colas la chef de file de l'union de la
gauche dans ce département et au second
tour et bien elle affrontera un binôme
du rassemblement national
merci gabriel de quelques résultats
rapidement me dit-on dans l'oreillette
je vous raconte tout donc rapidement
au valdahon dans le doubs donc le canton
de valdahon dans le doubs il y avait une
primaire à droite et c'est donc le
candidat estampillé majorité
départementale de christine bouquin qui
arrive en tête avec près de 40% des
suffrages doxil vieillir qui faisait
binôme avec thierry vernet en 2015
arrive en deuxième position donc que 27%
et se retrouve donc en ballottage ces
deux binômes donc droite ou divers
droite à me lisez en haute-saône donc
dans le département de la haute saône
sylvie coûte rue et laurent seguin qui
sont donc les deux conseillers
départementaux sortant de ce mid nonne
sont en ballottage très favorable
puisqu'ils sont largement devant le duo
est de droite à savoir philippe grosjean
et anne lagarrigue respectivement 55%
des suffrages et 28 pour cent mais la
participation n'était pas suffisamment
élevé pour qu'il soit élu dès le premier
tour
et puis autres cantons de haute saône à
dampierre sur salon
dimitri doussot et martin gautron sont
en ballottage très favorable avec plus
de 54%
c'était déjà un canton qui était à
droite et il est bien parti pour
dimanche prochain le reste est elle le
rassemblement national arrive troisième
et donc battu et éliminé
je termine avec les résultats de lons le
saunier on sait qu'à lanceuse ognier la
succession de l'ancien maire jacques
pélissard est très difficile à droite
qu'il ya plusieurs courants et des
rivalités pour le canton de lons le
saunier 2 cyrille brero qui est le
candidat sortant conseiller
départemental est en ballottage
favorable avec 37% devant un binôme de
gauche composé d'yves hambourgeois et de
emilie goujon 37% pour l'un 22% pour
l'autre et c'est à peu près donc les
résultats principaux que nous avons pour
le moment et est là je vais donc vous
rendre l'antenne pour parler des
régionales
merci beaucoup catherine jérémy un mot
sur les dernières estimations
oui avec cette estimation ipsos oppresse
steria marie-guite dufay basculer en
tête de ce premier tour marie-guite
dufay la présidente socialiste sortante
avec 26 6% des suffrages devant julien
odoul du rassemblement national 23,6
pour cent
gilles platret les républicains à 21 2%
et denis thuriau de la république en
marche
11,9 pour cent stéphanie modde d'europe
écologie les verts est autour de 10%
bastien faudot 4,4 et claire rocher 2,6
pour cent
et justement jérémy je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction de claire rocher
pour lutte ouvrière on écoute c'est un
gage pour l'avenir parce que les listes
lutte ouvrière elle était clairement des
listes pour un programme de lutte pour
les travailleurs et dans la perspective
de renverser le pouvoir de la
bourgeoisie et donc c'est un gage pour
l'avenir d'avoir plus d'une dizaine de
milliers d'électeurs dans la région
bourgogne franche comté qui se prononce
sur ce programme là et sur cette
perspective voilà avant de poursuivre la
discussion en plateau ici avec nos
invités je vous propose de revenir sur
la soirée de julien odoul la tête de
liste du rassemblement national qui a
donc réalisé 23% des suffrages aux
cartes il voulait la première place le
devant de la scène à l'issue du premier
tour mais c'est un julien odoul second
qui arrive devant les journalistes un
candidat du fn
déçu par son score et par ce qu'il
appelle une désertion démocratique où
êtes vous où êtes-vous ce soir où êtes
vous ce soir pour faire gagner nos idées
c'est à vous de nous donner la victoire
c'est à vous de vous mobiliser dimanche
prochain
la victoire est possible si vous bougez
pendant la campagne il avait tendu la
main à gilles platret le candidat des
républicains
en vain ce soir il lui tend de nouveau
monsieur platret prendra ses
responsabilités moi j'ai toujours tendu
la main
j'ai toujours tendu la main parce que je
considère que l'enjeu il est immense
l'enjeu c'est celui de l'alternance il
s'agit pas de partie il s'agit pas de
tête de liste là il s'agit de voter
utile et le seul vote utile c'est la
candeur c'est le vote rassemblement
national au qg de julien ou double ce
dimanche il n'aura donc pas eu
d'explosion de joie de disques
pour deux victoires avec 23% le
rassemblement national fait bien moins
qu'en 2015 pour les dernières élections
régionales le parti de marine le pen
était arrivé en tête au premier tour
avec 31% des voix
alain joyandet
je me tourne vers vous julien en double
a clairement fait appel à votre liste
vous avez fait campagne quasiment sur
les mêmes thèmes pourquoi ne pas s'unir
je crois que gilles platret vous a donné
la réponse tout à l'heure on aimerait
avoir la vôtre donc pourquoi la mienne
sur est elle différente de la sienne
donc je pense qu'on a fait la campagne
qui était la nôtre nous avons dit depuis
le début que nous avions un projet de
large rassemblement j'ai d'ailleurs eu
assez de polémique puisque vous en
souvenez rassemblement avec monsieur du
comté niort avait suscité quelques
commentaires assez acerbe donc on a un
rassemblement qui est déjà très très
large qui va jusqu aux écologistes de
monsieur waechter nous avons notre
projet nous avons notre liste et on va
pas on va pas entre les deux tours
changer quoi que ce soit je peux juste
me permettre j'ai pas parlé continent je
suis là de lancer un appel aux
abstentionnistes en leur disant que la
véritable alternance elle est toujours
possible à partir du moment où j'ai
aussi beaucoup de demandes et
l'alternance madame du fait est là
depuis très longtemps à les socialistes
voulaient si je termine simplement tout
le monde en à peine quinze jours dire
pour dire que l'alternance au delà de
l'appel aux abstentionnistes je pense
que l'alternance serait quelque chose de
sain pour la bourgogne franche comté
fanny mode vous nous avez rejoint
faisaient donc la tête de liste d'europe
écologie les verts et du pôle écologiste
vous êtes autour de 10% ce soir alors
9,7 dans notre estimation un peu plus de
10% sur 96% des bulletins dépouillés
c'est en train de bouger est ce que
c'est un sport qui vous satisfait c'est
un score qui en tout cas mais l'écologie
politique le projet écologiste qui
l'inscrit dans la région bourgogne
franche comté donc à ce titre là
effectivement je suis satisfait si on
passe la barre symbolique des 10 pour ça
veut dire que vous allez peser dans les
négociations du coup avec cette date là
nous avons avec les très bons résultats
de marie-guite dufay que je salue pour
ces très bons résultats
nous avons la possibilité d'avoir une
région en créant
c'est avec les écologistes donc
effectivement moi c'est mon souhait
c'est qu'on puisse vraiment garder cette
région à gauche mais avec des
écologistes qui n'avaient pas pu être le
cas en 2015 il ya des pierres
d'achoppement entre vous deux il ya déjà
beaucoup donné à des discussions qui
sont en cours qu'on va continuer il ya
des projets en tout cas qui est sur le
volet social ya beaucoup beaucoup de
points d'accord il y en a quelques-uns
de désaccord mais je suis persuadé qu'on
va pouvoir s'entendre vraiment pour
pouvoir vraiment porter cette région
bourgogne franche comté vers un projet
encore plus ancré dans dans dans
l'écologie politique et dans un projet
social et autour effectivement des
valeurs qui sont comme une oie je suis
écologiste et tout écologiste à des
valeurs de bouche voilà je pense que c
est valeurs communes ont des valeurs que
vous écoutiez attentivement marie-guite
dufay vous êtes d'accord vous souscrivez
à ce que vient de dire stéphanie modde
oui il y a beaucoup de choses qui nous
rassemble il y a des choses qui te nous
rassemble pas mais ça c'est comme dans
toutes les familles
on n'est pas unie sur tout et vous ferez
décombres là nous trouverons j'espère
que nous trouverons un compromis
on n'est pas obligé d'être d'accord sur
tout et la corse ce sera effectivement
un accord très précis avec des points de
désaccord qui ne feront pas partie
effectivement dont l'entrée est libre
maintenant pourquoi ne pas dire
maintenant parce que c'est quand même
terrible pour que ne pas dire ou es aux
électeurs que vous êtes déjà d'accord
avant le premier tour pour fusionner
volistes vos listes elles sont faites
pour être fusionnées donc vous dites les
électeurs sont sont perdus mais dit un
peu la vérité dit lui même la carte mais
on va laisser à mariner des responsables
lors dé la partie de la vérité lors des
lâchers raté avait très bien ciblé
or là de nous le dire je n'aime pas la
joie yandé alors je voyais en début aux
élus d'être là on va lui laisser
répondre marié d'évacuation que tout est
déjà prévu tout cela mais les landais
liste est déjà prêt mais absolument pas
ce soir absolument pas rien les jours à
mes prenez tous les bars
nous jeunes à peu la vérité quoi la
vérité oui la vérité si vous êtes
d'accord en plus de monde
je suis pour la vérité comme un slogan
viol est d'accord avec moi d'ailleurs
alors qu'il ya beaucoup plus de choses
qui nous rassemble que de choses qui
nous divisent entre logique poursuit
mais le reste de la gamme
je stoppe s'il vous plaît on écoute
parlera pas de rire ce qui reste
quelques secondes j'ai compris j'ai
compris que madame buffet souhaitait
négocier et discuter avec les
écologistes
on l'avait vu lors du débat qui avait
déjà une entente entre les gens de
gauche ça se voit et votre candidat lui
elle faisait des appels soit aussi j'ai
entendu que manifeste dit qu'elle
refusait de discuter avec nous alors que
nous souhaitons qu'elle élargit sa
majorité discuter avec elles
travaillaient ensemble leur bataille a
dit que ça veut dire que vous
présenterez une liste dimanche prochain
on va en décider cette nuit nous
attendions la réponse de madame du fait
nous l'avons je déciderai avec les amis
ce soir c'est par ims et de ninh nord ce
soir cinéma qu'il dit et parisse tout
l'été de vis qui vont être qu'ils vont
faire ensemble dites moi une chose quand
même
la dernière fois 2015 le front à 80 en
bourgogne il est aujourd'hui à 23 je
constate une chose c'est emmanuel macron
a fait du front national et l'extrême
droite son ennemi et que ce soir il a
réussi à les faire baisser
allez on va revoir justement avant de se
quitter les résultats de ce soir sondage
estimations pardon ipsos osteria sortie
des urnes marie-guite dufay basculerait
donc en tête ce soir avec 26 6% des
suffrages devant julien odoul du
rassemblement national un peu plus de 23
suivent gilles platret et denis turion
merci et renault se retrouve demain dans
nos éditions pour faire le point on vous
dira tout et la paix prochaine merci à
tous merci à vous d'être venus en bateau
et merci
[Musique]
tous